Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Martin Luther's life was about to change forever. Three incidents from his time in Erfurt stand out, hinting at some of the anguish this young man, apparently destined for a successful career, was suffering. First, a fellow student and friend fell ill and died. His death affected Luther deeply and appears to have plunged him into melancholy. Then, while travelling home to Mansfeld, about half a mile out of Erfurt, he somehow managed to injure himself with his sword,
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。马丁·路德的人生即将发生永久性的改变。他在埃尔福特（Erfurt）时期的三件事尤为突出，暗示了这位本应拥有成功职业生涯的年轻人内心所承受的痛苦。首先，他的一位同学兼好友生病去世了。好友的死对路德影响深远，似乎让他陷入了忧郁之中。随后，在回曼斯费尔德（Mansfeld）的途中，离埃尔福特约半英里远的地方，他不知怎的用自己的剑伤到了自己，
severing an artery at the top of his leg. He pressed his finger on the wound to stop the bleeding, but the leg began to swell up massively. Luther could easily have bled to death. Seized with terror, he prayed, Oh Mary, help! A doctor was summoned who treated the wound, but that evening, while Luther was lying in bed, the wound burst, and again he called on Mary to save him. It looked as if his prayers were answered, for the wound healed. So Tom Holland, that comes from Lyndall Roper's book, Martin Luther, Renegade and Prophet. I guess one question that could hang over this podcast, this episode, and this whole series is, had he bled to death, how different
割断了腿部上方的一条动脉。他用手指按住伤口止血，但腿部开始严重肿胀。路德很可能会因失血过多而死。惊恐万分的他祈祷道：“圣母玛利亚，救救我！”医生被叫来处理了伤口，但那天晚上，当路德躺在床上时，伤口崩裂了，他再次呼求玛利亚救他。看起来他的祈祷得到了回应，因为伤口愈合了。那么，汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland），这段内容出自琳达·罗珀（Lyndall Roper）的著作《马丁·路德：叛逆者与先知》（Martin Luther, Renegade and Prophet）。我想，在这个播客、这一集以及整个系列中，有一个悬而未决的问题：如果他当时失血过多而死，那么
would the history, A, of what we call the Reformation, but B, the world since the year 1500, how different would it have been? And you would probably say it would be incalculably different because you think Luther really, he's a change maker. He really matters. It's not just the context and the conditions, but it's this one individual that genuinely changes the course of history. I do, Dominic. I think he is like a lightning bolt. Right. Striking and, you know, you've got all the ingredients for life waiting in that kind of little pond, but it takes the lightning bolt to generate life. And I think you could say the same
历史——A，我们所说的宗教改革；B，1500年以后的世界——会有多大的不同？你可能会说会有不可估量的不同，因为你认为路德确实是一个变革者。他真的很重要。这不仅仅是背景和条件的问题，而是这个个体真正改变了历史的进程。确实如此，多米尼克。我认为他就像一道闪电。没错。击中目标，你知道，所有生命的要素都在那个小池塘里等待着，但需要闪电来激发生命。我想你也可以这样说
about Luther. And on the topic of lightning, Dominic, attentive listeners to that passage, Linda Roper mentioned three episodes. She did. I noticed that. Yeah. Where's the third? And so people may be wondering what the third is. Well, the third involves lightning and thunder and a thunderstorm. Because shortly after that accident with the sword, the young Luther, and just to recap, we left him in part one. He was a student who's just graduated and his father is intending him to go and train to be a lawyer so that he can go back to the mining town and help sort out his smelting and all that kind of thing.
关于路德。说到闪电，多米尼克，仔细听那段话的听众会注意到，琳达·罗珀提到了三件事。她确实提到了。我注意到了。是的。第三件事在哪里？所以人们可能想知道第三件事是什么。嗯，第三件事涉及闪电、雷声和一场雷雨。因为在那次剑伤事故后不久，年轻的路德——简单回顾一下，我们在第一部分把他留在了那里——他是一名刚毕业的学生，他的父亲打算让他去学习法律，这样他就可以回到矿业小镇，帮忙打理冶炼生意以及诸如此类的事情。
So to paint the picture, we are in Saxony, in the southeastern corner of modern day Germany, in roughly, what are we? He's born in 1483. So in the very early 1500s. June 1505. And so he rides from Erfurt, where he has been studying, to Mansfeld, where his parents live and where his father is busy making brass out of muck. And he's riding back from Mansfeld to Erfurt when suddenly there is this terrifying thunderstorm.
为了描绘当时的场景，我们身处萨克森（Saxony），位于现代德国的东南角，大约在……我们现在是什么时候？他出生于1483年。所以是在1500年代初期。1505年6月。他从求学的埃尔福特骑马前往父母居住的曼斯费尔德，他父亲正忙着在那里“点石成金”（从矿渣中提炼黄铜）。就在他从曼斯费尔德骑马回埃尔福特的路上，突然遭遇了这场可怕的雷雨。
And it's so terrifying that Luther raises up a prayer and he prays to St. Anne, who we mentioned in the first part is the patron saint of minors and the mother of Mary. Oh yes yes of course yeah and he cries out help me saint anne and if you do i will become a monk so it's quite a vow to make must i mean what a hell of a thunderstorm tom so there's clearly a sense that there is something out of the ordinary about it a kind of supernatural quality to it. And in time, people will debate, well, you know, was it a thunderstorm sent by God or by the devil? And so what Martin is doing, though, is actually, you know, by the standards of piety of the age, nothing unusual. So he's invoking a celestial patron, in this case,
这场雷雨太可怕了，以至于路德向上帝祈祷，他向圣安妮（St. Anne）祈祷——我们在第一部分提到过，她是矿工的守护神，也是玛利亚的母亲。哦，是的，当然，是的。他大喊：“救救我，圣安妮！如果你救我，我就去当修士。”所以这是一个相当重的誓言。汤姆，那得是多么可怕的一场雷雨啊。显然，人们感觉到这件事非同寻常，有一种超自然的特质。久而久之，人们会争论，嗯，你知道，这到底是上帝派来的雷雨，还是魔鬼派来的？但马丁所做的，其实以那个时代的虔诚标准来看，并没有什么不寻常。所以他是在祈求一位天上的守护者，在这种情况下是
Saint Anne, and he is promising in exchange for her help, he's making a promise. And what he is doing is promising that he will become a monk. But this is typical of the spiritual economy that we were talking about in the first half, this idea that you have to make down payments, whether to get the help of heaven or to clear your sins or whatever. And Martin is instinctively buying into that. And he's offering himself up as a monk,
圣安妮，他以换取她的帮助为条件，许下了一个承诺。他承诺自己将成为一名修士。但这正是我们在前半部分讨论的“属灵经济”的典型表现，即你必须支付预付款，无论是为了获得天堂的帮助，还是为了洗清罪孽等等。马丁本能地接受了这一点。他主动提出要成为一名修士，
partly because by doing that, he's consecrating himself to God in a way that he wouldn't be doing as a lawyer. But also I think because there is clearly something in Luther's psyche that is drawing him to the idea that God might redeem him. He's craving it. He's desperate for it. And by becoming a monk, you are on a kind of fast track to God. The way is narrow, it's severe, but it is straight. And there's this kind of promise that by becoming a monk,
部分原因是他这样做是在以一种作为律师无法做到的方式将自己奉献给上帝。但我认为，路德的心理中显然有一种东西在吸引他，让他觉得上帝可能会救赎他。他渴望救赎，他对此感到绝望。而通过成为一名修士，你就走上了一条通往上帝的“快车道”。这条路狭窄、严苛，但它是笔直的。而且有一种承诺，即通过成为一名修士，
you can perfect yourself. You can become closer to God. You can cleanse yourself of sin and thereby be that much closer to heaven. So a couple of things that strike me. Number one is when he makes that decision to become a monk, what many listeners, the thing that would have struck them is you're basically swearing yourself to a life of celibacy. Yeah. So that's part of it, right? Yes, absolutely.
你可以完善自己。你可以变得更接近上帝。你可以洗清自己的罪孽，从而离天堂更近一步。所以有几件事让我印象深刻。第一，当他做出成为修士的决定时，许多听众会感到震惊的一点是，你基本上是发誓要过独身生活。是的。所以这也是其中的一部分，对吧？是的，绝对是。
And at that point, as far as we know, he's had no dealings with women. He hasn't got a girlfriend or whatever. We don't know. Secondly, most people would not do that. I mean, most people don't become monks. You know, the young Henry VIII caught in a thunderstorm. There's no circumstance in which he would say, do you know what, I'm going to become a monk.
而且在那一点上，据我们所知，他还没有和女性有过任何交往。他没有女朋友什么的。我们不知道。其次，大多数人不会那样做。我的意思是，大多数人不会成为修士。你知道，年轻的亨利八世如果被困在雷雨中，在任何情况下他都不会说：“你知道吗，我要去当修士。”
I mean, that's just not going to happen. Luther, there must be some psychological thing already there. It must have occurred to him that he could become a monk. Don't you think? Well, you might say, I'll go on a pilgrimage or I'll do this or I'll do that. I'll say so many Hail Marys or candles or whatever. So you might do that. But I right exactly so lindell rope's biography which is one of a multitude that came out in 2017 to mark the 500th anniversary of supposed start of the reformation she's very interested in the psychology of luther yeah and kind of argues that luther is intimidated by his own father that he is a brooding, menacing presence. And that now that he's completed his studies, he's going to have to become a lawyer, then he's going to go back and he's going to kind of join the family firm.
我的意思是，那是不可能发生的。路德，他内心一定已经有了某种心理因素。他一定想到过自己可以成为修士。你不觉得吗？嗯，你可能会说，我会去朝圣，或者我会做这个，或者我会做那个。我会念多少遍《圣母经》或者点蜡烛什么的。所以你可能会那样做。但我……完全正确。琳达·罗珀的传记——这是2017年为纪念宗教改革开始500周年而出版的众多传记之一——她对路德的心理非常感兴趣，是的，她认为路德被他自己的父亲所威慑，父亲是一个阴郁、具有威胁性的存在。现在他完成了学业，他将不得不成为一名律师，然后他将回到家乡，加入家族企业。
Oh, right. Yeah. You know, if we want to pursue the idea that this is something that's happening in a 1950s kitchen sink drama, this is like, you know, the guy who's gone off to grammar school in university and now he doesn't want to go back home. He wants to go off and become a poet or something. Or go to Paris and write a play or something. You'll come back here, son. I've got a job for you at the firm, solicitors at the firm. I've got a lot of legal business for you to do in Bradford, that kind of thing. Father, I want to write poetry. Exactly. And she also makes out that by becoming a monk, you are committing yourself
哦，对。是的。你知道，如果我们想用1950年代厨房水槽剧（现实主义题材）的视角来看待这件事，这就像是，你知道，那个去了文法学校和大学的年轻人，现在不想回家了。他想去当诗人什么的。或者去巴黎写剧本什么的。“儿子，回这里来。我在公司给你找了份工作，律师事务所。我在布拉德福德（Bradford）有很多法律业务要你处理，诸如此类。”“父亲，我想写诗。”完全正确。她还指出，通过成为一名修士，你是在将自己奉献给
to God the Father. So you were looking for the love of another father. And I think that there's a very convincing case, which Linda Roper makes with all the immense learning that she has and scholarship, that something like this is going on. That Luther wouldn't put it exactly in those terms, but that he is turning from an earthly father to a heavenly father. And that by becoming a monk, you are dramatizing that in the most flamboyant way. And it has to be said that dramatizing things in flamboyant ways will be a feature of Luther's behavior from now on. I know that there've been other scholars, haven't they, written about the young Luther, and this is very controversial, but that point seems to me totally psychologically plausible,
天父。所以你是在寻找另一位父亲的爱。我认为琳达·罗珀凭借她渊博的学识和研究，提出了一个非常有说服力的观点，即类似这样的事情正在发生。路德可能不会用这些确切的词汇来表达，但他正在从一位世俗的父亲转向一位天上的父亲。而通过成为一名修士，他正在以最张扬的方式将这种转变戏剧化。必须说，以张扬的方式戏剧化事物将成为路德此后行为的一个特征。我知道还有其他学者写过关于年轻路德的文章，这非常有争议，但这一点在我看来在心理上是完全合理的，
that this is a way of wriggling out of going back with his dad. And actually, you know, it's a slight slap in the face to his dad, but it's also a way of finding a new kind of community for himself and a new, yeah, I guess guess father figure or whatever. But I think that thing that it is a very dramatic way of behaving. So you were saying most people don't do this. I mean, Luther has an absolute genius for the action that reverberates. And, you know, I mean, effectively at this point, his audience is his parents, but he will have a genius for drawing attention to himself and will end up the star of, you know, the whole of Europe will be watching him.
这是一种摆脱跟随父亲回去的方式。实际上，你知道，这对他父亲来说是一个小小的耳光，但这也是他为自己寻找一种新社区和一种……是的，我想是父亲形象或什么的。但我认为，这是一种非常戏剧化的行为方式。所以你刚才说大多数人不会这样做。我的意思是，路德有一种绝对的天赋，能做出引起轰动的行为。而且，你知道，我的意思是，在这一点上，他的观众实际上是他的父母，但他将拥有一种吸引注意力的天赋，最终他将成为……整个欧洲都会注视着他。
So I think that this is a kind of the first example we get from his biography of that particular talent. And he joins the Augustinian order in Erfurt. And the Augustinians are highly intellectual, highly severe, and they are also known as defenders of orthodoxy. So the high altar of the monastery at Erfurt, there's a tomb of a very distinguished theologian called Andreas Zacharias. And again, Lyndall Roper draws attention to this, that he is a theologian who had played a key role in the condemnation of Jan Hus, the Bohemian heretic who ends up being burnt by the imperial authorities,
所以我认为这是我们在他的传记中看到的这种特殊才能的第一个例子。他加入了埃尔福特的奥古斯丁修会（Augustinian order）。奥古斯丁派修士博学、严苛，而且他们也被称为正统的捍卫者。埃尔福特修道院的主祭坛上，有一位非常杰出的神学家安德烈亚斯·扎卡里亚斯（Andreas Zacharias）的墓。同样，琳达·罗珀提请注意这一点，即这位神学家在谴责波希米亚异端扬·胡斯（Jan Hus）的过程中发挥了关键作用，胡斯最终被帝国当局烧死，
despite the fact that the emperor-to-be had given him a safe conduct. So Luther would have been very aware of this. Going to that monastery, the role played by this man, Zacharias, the monastery would have been proud of it. So he becomes a monk. The top of his head is a tonsil, as it's called. It's shaved and he gets the black cowl and everything. And he's already got his academic gown and ring as a student. You know, this is the marker of the man who was going to become the lawyer. He sends this back to daddy. Oh, that's a bit of a slap in the face, isn't it? And daddy is furious. So anyone who's seen the John Osborne play, I mean, this is kind of the heart of the action at the beginning of the play. And a feast is held to celebrate Luther's first mass. And Luther's father,
尽管未来的皇帝曾给予他安全通行证。所以路德对此会非常清楚。进入那个修道院，这个叫扎卡里亚斯的人所扮演的角色，修道院会以此为荣。于是他成为了一名修士。他的头顶被剃成了“僧侣发型”（tonsure）。他剃了头，穿上了黑色的僧袍等等。他作为学生时已经有了学术长袍和戒指。你知道，这是那个将要成为律师的人的标志。他把这些寄回给了老爸。哦，那真是个耳光，不是吗？老爸非常愤怒。所以任何看过约翰·奥斯本（John Osborne）剧作的人，我的意思是，这在剧作开头是行动的核心。为了庆祝路德的第一次弥撒，举行了一场盛宴。路德的父亲，
he pays for it with a kind of extravagant grant of cash, but he still clearly has not forgiven his son and after the mass luther asks his father you know well i hope that you accept my decision now i hope that you know no hard feelings about this and hans luder stands up and in front of all luther's fellow monks he says remember the fourth commandment obey your father and your mother. And then he says, you know, and you were saying it must've been a dramatic storm. He says, what if it was an evil spirit who conjured up this storm? I know. And that's an incredibly unsettling thing for him to say to his son, because essentially what he's saying is that you've been tricked by the devil. And I wonder, Hamlet will become a student at Wittenberg,
他用一笔慷慨的现金资助了这场宴会，但他显然仍然没有原谅他的儿子。弥撒结束后，路德问他的父亲：“你知道，我希望你现在能接受我的决定，我希望你知道，对此没有芥蒂。”汉斯·路德（Hans Luder）站起来，在路德所有的修士同僚面前说：“记住第四条诫命：孝敬你的父亲和母亲。”然后他说，你知道，你刚才说那一定是一场戏剧性的风暴。他说：“如果是一个邪灵召唤了这场风暴呢？”我知道。对他儿子说出这样的话是非常令人不安的，因为他本质上是在说，你被魔鬼欺骗了。我想，哈姆雷特将成为维滕贝格（Wittenberg）的学生，
where Luther will go on to become a professor. And this question of whether things are conjured up by the devil or whether they are authentic, you know it's something that hangs over hamlet as well so the question of whether it's divine or diabolical i mean you know his father brings it up at this primal moment where he's just celebrated his first mass and tom i know we'll come back to this later on in the episode but this character very much not a friend of the rest is history the devil yes so when his father says that an evil spirit the devil they are living in a world rather like we talked about last time about belief the nature of belief and taking things for granted yes they're living in a world where it would be totally taken for granted that the devil exists and that there are evil spirits and that you can
路德后来将在那里成为教授。关于事情是魔鬼召唤的还是真实的这个问题，你知道，这也笼罩在哈姆雷特身上。所以关于它是神圣的还是邪恶的问题，我的意思是，你知道，他的父亲在他刚刚庆祝完第一次弥撒这个原始时刻提到了这一点。汤姆，我知道我们稍后会在这一集中回到这一点，但这个角色——非常不是《历史的余味》的朋友——魔鬼。是的，所以当他的父亲说邪灵、魔鬼时，他们生活在一个像我们上次谈论的那样关于信仰、信仰本质以及认为事情理所当然的世界里。是的，他们生活在一个完全认为魔鬼存在、有邪灵存在，并且你可能会
be corrupted in this way absolutely and i think again, a thing that characterizes Luther's distinctive spirituality is that the devil is vividly real for him. And later on, we'll have a look at the distinctive way in which Luther understands the devil. Because I think the dread of the devil is the counterpoint of his yearning for God. And as a monk, he is set on the path that will lead him to heaven. But he struggles to feel God's love. And I think that this is a cause of immense trauma for him. So later in his life, he talks about this. Though I lived as a monk without reproach, he says, I felt that I was a sinner before God with an extremely disturbed conscience. I could not believe that he was placated by my satisfactions. I did not love, yes, I hated the righteous God who punishes sinners,
以这种方式被腐蚀的世界里。绝对是这样。而且我认为，再次强调，路德独特灵性的一个特征是，魔鬼对他来说是生动真实的。稍后，我们将看看路德理解魔鬼的独特方式。因为我认为对魔鬼的恐惧是他对上帝渴望的对立面。作为一名修士，他走上了通往天堂的道路。但他努力去感受上帝的爱。我认为这是他巨大创伤的根源。所以在他生命的后期，他谈到了这一点。他说：“虽然我作为一名修士过着无可指责的生活，但我感到自己在上帝面前是一个罪人，良心极其不安。我无法相信他会因我的满足而平息。我不爱，是的，我恨那位惩罚罪人的公义上帝，
and secretly, if not blasphemously, certainly murmuring greatly, I was angry with God. I raged with a fierce and troubled conscience. So this is what he's saying shortly before his death. That idea that he hates God, I mean, he still believes in God, but he hates him because he feels that he hates God. I mean, he still believes in God, but he hates him because he feels that he cannot possibly live up to, be good enough. He can't be good enough. He can't purge away his sin. And so therefore God, who is righteous, will sit in judgment on him. And this causes him enormous
暗地里，如果不是亵渎的话，肯定是在极大地抱怨，我生上帝的气。我在激烈而不安的良心中愤怒。”所以这是他在去世前不久所说的。那种他恨上帝的想法，我的意思是，他仍然相信上帝，但他恨他，因为他觉得……他恨上帝。我的意思是，他仍然相信上帝，但他恨他，因为他觉得他不可能达到要求，不可能足够好。他不够好。他无法洗清自己的罪孽。因此，公义的上帝将对他进行审判。这让他感到巨大的
dread. And that thing about, you said he struggled to find God's love. Is there a sense in which he joined the monastery, he thought he would get this wonderful glow of living in God's love and stuff, and the glow doesn't come. And so he's raging because later on he uses the phrase, doesn't he? He's really struck by the phrase from St. Paul about being born again. So is he somebody who's almost yearning to be born again at this point, but hasn't been born again, basically? Well, he doesn't know that. What he wants is to feel God's love, but he feels unworthy of God's love. And so this sets him as a monk on a course of extreme asceticism. I was wondering whether there's a bit of self-loathing going on through all this. Oh, for sure. But I think it's also competitive. He wants to be the holiest. Luther,
恐惧。关于你说的他努力去感受上帝的爱，有没有这样一种感觉：他加入修道院时，以为自己会感受到那种生活在上帝爱中的美妙光辉，但这种光辉并没有到来。所以他很愤怒，因为后来他用了那个短语，不是吗？他被圣保罗关于“重生”的短语深深打动了。所以他是一个在这一点上几乎渴望重生，但基本上还没有重生的人吗？嗯，他不知道这一点。他想要的是感受上帝的爱，但他觉得自己不配得到上帝的爱。因此，这使他作为一名修士走上了一条极端禁欲主义的道路。我一直在想，这一切过程中是否有一种自我厌恶。哦，当然。但我认为这也是竞争性的。他想成为最圣洁的人。路德，
all his life, is very competitive. But I think also it's driven by consciousness of his own sinfulness and the anxiety that he can never do enough to win salvation, that this is what is driving him. And so no amount of saying prayers or expiatory works or prayers to saints to intercede for him with God. None of this can help. And the sense therefore, actually, that despite the fact that you have this enormous kind of supernatural framework that the medieval church has constructed to facilitate the sense people have that they're coming to God, that actually Luther just feels that he's completely alone. And so as a monk, he says, I was always sweating. I imagine a lot of BO, kind of sweaty, he's skinny, glaring eyes. I mean, a kind of unsettling figure.
他一生都非常有竞争力。但我认为这也是由他对自己罪孽的意识以及他永远无法做足够多的事情来赢得救赎的焦虑所驱动的，这就是驱动他的东西。所以无论念多少次祈祷、做多少赎罪工作，或者向圣徒祈祷让他们在上帝面前为他代求，这些都无济于事。因此，尽管中世纪教会构建了这种巨大的超自然框架来促进人们对接近上帝的感觉，但路德实际上只是觉得他完全孤独。所以作为一名修士，他说：“我总是汗流浃背。”我能想象出很多体味，那种汗津津的，他很瘦，眼睛瞪得大大的。我的意思是，一个令人不安的人物。
Yeah, really selling him, Tom. Right. But the thing is that monasteries are actually used to people like Luther. Monasteries have been going for a long, long time, over a thousand years. And the heads of monasteries are used to monks who get this kind of anxiety that they're not holy enough. And Luther is very lucky that the head of the Augustinian order in Germany, a man called Johann von Staupitz, is actually very sympathetic and kind of admires Luther and wants to help him in his spiritual crisis. So he becomes Luther's confessor. So Luther can confess his sins and be absolved by Staupitz. Luther goes all in.
是的，汤姆，你真是在推销他。没错。但问题是，修道院实际上习惯了像路德这样的人。修道院已经存在了很长很长一段时间，超过一千年了。修道院的院长们习惯了那些因为觉得自己不够圣洁而产生这种焦虑的修士。路德非常幸运，德国奥古斯丁修会的负责人，一个叫约翰·冯·施陶皮茨（Johann von Staupitz）的人，实际上非常富有同情心，而且很欣赏路德，想要帮助他度过精神危机。于是他成了路德的忏悔神父。所以路德可以向施陶皮茨忏悔他的罪孽并获得赦免。路德全力以赴。
So he is confessing for three, four, five, six hours at a time. And Tom, here's a slightly banal question. What on earth is he confessing to? So he's probably confessing to, I hate some of the other monks. I feel lust for women. Well, interestingly, it doesn't seem to have been lust. So celibacy doesn't seem to have particularly tortured him. There are obviously lots of monks who really are tortured by that, but it doesn't seem to have been something that Luther particularly worried about. I think it's this feeling of inadequacy before
所以他一次忏悔三、四、五个小时。汤姆，这是一个稍微平庸的问题。他到底在忏悔什么？所以他可能在忏悔：“我讨厌其他一些修士。我对女性感到欲望。”嗯，有趣的是，这似乎不是欲望。所以独身生活似乎并没有特别折磨他。显然有很多修士确实为此感到痛苦，但这似乎并不是路德特别担心的事情。我认为这是他在上帝面前感到不足的感觉，
God, this feeling that God is judging him, is finding that he's come short and therefore Luther hates and fears God as a result, and that simply compounds his feelings of dread. Because if you hate God, then who's to say that you're not on the side of the devil? Six hours of listening to that, though, Tom. Yeah, exactly. And so Staupitz, unsurprisingly, kind of thinks, well, you know, this is too much. I mean, he's just obsessing. So he needs to basically get out and do something else.
这种感觉是上帝在审判他，发现他做得不够，因此路德恨并惧怕上帝，这只会加剧他的恐惧感。因为如果你恨上帝，那么谁能说你不是站在魔鬼那一边呢？听这些话听了六个小时，汤姆。是的，完全正确。所以施陶皮茨不出所料地认为，嗯，你知道，这太过分了。我的意思是，他只是在钻牛角尖。所以他需要基本上走出去做点别的事情。
And so he says, you should go and study for a doctorate in theology. They'll find a load of really miserable, negative people. Yeah, go and join a university. They'll find a load of really miserable, negative people. Yeah, go join a university. That'll cheer you up. So he gets, in 1508-9, he leaves Erfurt and the monastery and he goes to Wittenberg, which is the place where the Elector of Saxony has his capital. And by this point, the Elector of Saxony is no longer Ernst, who was Elector when
于是他说：“你应该去攻读神学博士学位。”他们会找到一大堆非常悲惨、消极的人。是的，去加入一所大学。他们会找到一大堆非常悲惨、消极的人。是的，去加入一所大学。那会让你振作起来的。所以他在1508-9年离开了埃尔福特和修道院，去了维滕贝格，那是萨克森选帝侯拥有其首都的地方。到这个时候，萨克森选帝侯不再是恩斯特（Ernst），也就是路德出生时的选帝侯，而是一个叫弗雷德里希（Frederick）的人，他在1486年成为选帝侯，当时路德才三岁，在恩斯特从马上摔下来之后……多米尼克，科尔迪茨（Colditz）。
Luther was born, but a man called Frederick, who had become Elector in 1486, so when Luther was only three, after Ernst had fallen off his horse at Dominic, cold it's. Cold it's, I saw that, yeah. So the place where all the British prisoners of war tried to escape. Yeah, very good board game. Yeah. So he gets to be called Frederick the Wise. So he is the Elector of Saxony, one of the seven electors who elect the Emperor. And he is very ambitious for Wittenberg. So when Luther arrives there, the whole place is an absolute building site. You've got a castle at one end where the Elector has his base.
科尔迪茨，我看到了，是的。所以那个所有英国战俘都试图逃跑的地方。是的，非常好的棋盘游戏。是的。所以他被称为“智者弗雷德里希”（Frederick the Wise）。所以他是萨克森选帝侯，七位选举皇帝的选帝侯之一。他对比维滕贝格非常有野心。所以当路德到达那里时，整个地方就是一个巨大的建筑工地。你有一端是城堡，选帝侯在那里有他的基地。
You have the monastery, Augustinian Monastery, which is where Luther's going, and the university at the other. And it's a building site because Frederick is extending the castle and he is building the university from scratch. And also just for good measure, he's building an enormous town hall that will take decades and decades to complete. And just, can I say something about Frederick and Saxony? Because I think it's really important. So two things. One, Saxony had been divided between two branches of the family, hadn't it? So there's ducal Saxony and electoral Saxony.
你有修道院，奥古斯丁修道院，那是路德要去的地方，另一端是大学。这是一个建筑工地，因为弗雷德里希正在扩建城堡，他正在从零开始建造大学。而且为了保险起见，他还在建造一个巨大的市政厅，这将花费几十年才能完工。而且，我能说一下关于弗雷德里希和萨克森的事情吗？因为我认为这真的很重要。所以两件事。第一，萨克森在家族的两个分支之间被瓜分了，不是吗？所以有公爵萨克森和选帝侯萨克森。
Yes. So Saxony is part of this mad patchwork of the Holy Roman Empire. If you ever, you know, you want to make your eyes ache, you look at a map of the kind of all the free cities and stuff like that. So it's a little tiny bit like Northern Italy. It's very competitive and all the different rulers are trying to accumulate status symbols. So the university, this new university is massively important to Frederick and that will be very important in Luther's story. Hugely.
是的。所以萨克森是神圣罗马帝国这个疯狂拼凑体的一部分。如果你曾经，你知道，你想让你的眼睛酸痛，你就看一眼那种所有自由城市之类的地图。所以它有点像意大利北部。它非常有竞争力，所有的统治者都在试图积累地位象征。所以大学，这所新大学对弗雷德里希来说极其重要，这在路德的故事中将非常重要。非常重要。
But there's also something hugely important about Frederick. Because Frederick is the elector of Saxony, he is one of only seven people who get to choose the next Holy Roman Emperor, which means that even though he's not that powerful in European terms, other powerful people cannot afford to alienate him because that vote, one of only seven, is absolutely crucial. Yeah, absolutely. And will be very important in events that are to come. because that vote, one of only seven, is absolutely crucial. Yeah, absolutely. And will be very important in events that are to come. Yeah.
但关于弗雷德里希还有一些极其重要的事情。因为弗雷德里希是萨克森选帝侯，他是仅有的七个有权选择下一任神圣罗马帝国皇帝的人之一，这意味着即使他在欧洲范围内不是那么强大，其他强大的人也负担不起疏远他的代价，因为那一票，仅有的七票之一，是绝对至关重要的。是的，绝对是。而且在即将发生的事件中将非常重要。因为那一票，仅有的七票之一，是绝对至关重要的。是的，绝对是。而且在即将发生的事件中将非常重要。是的。
But in the meanwhile, you're right, he is desperate to put Wittenberg on the map. And he's able to do this because he's actually very rich, because he has lots of silver mines under his control. And so building the university, I suppose it's kind of like, I don't know, a Midwest town in the early 20th century wanting to put itself on the map by founding a university, that kind of thing. Or, I don't know, a capital in the Gulf building a massive art gallery or something like that. It's kind of developing cultural capital. But the other way in which Frederick puts Wittenberg on the map as well as building a university is that he's a massive collector of relics so this is another way that
但与此同时，你是对的，他非常渴望让维滕贝格出名。他能够做到这一点，因为他实际上非常有钱，因为他控制着大量的银矿。所以建造大学，我想这有点像，我不知道，20世纪初美国中西部的一个城镇想通过建立一所大学来让自己出名，就是那种感觉。或者，我不知道，海湾地区的一个首都建造一个巨大的美术馆之类的东西。这是一种发展文化资本。但弗雷德里希让维滕贝格出名的另一种方式，除了建立大学之外，就是他是一个巨大的圣物收藏家，所以这是另一种方式，
you can get to heaven is that you can go and pay your respects to a collection of relics and get time knocked off uh purgatory so frederick has an enormous collection so he has 19,013 fragments of saint's bones yeah he has a thorn from the crown of thorns that christ wears on the cross bonkers he has a twig from the burning bush seen by moses he has the swaddling clothes that the baby jesus was wrapped up in in the manger he has a lock of the virgin's hair. And I think most impressively of all, he has the entire corpse of one of the innocent babies of Bethlehem massacred by Herod's troops. Dominic is looking more and more Protestant by the minute as I read that list out. It makes Wittenberg an enormous focus of pilgrimage. If you go and reverence these relics-
你可以去天堂，那就是你可以去向一系列圣物致敬，并减少在炼狱的时间。所以弗雷德里希有一个巨大的收藏。他有19,013块圣徒骨头碎片。是的，他有基督在十字架上戴的荆棘冠上的一根刺。疯了。他有摩西看到的燃烧的荆棘丛中的一根树枝。他有婴儿耶稣在马槽里被包裹的襁褓。他有一缕圣母的头发。而且我认为最令人印象深刻的是，他拥有被希律王军队屠杀的伯利恒无辜婴儿中的一具完整尸体。多米尼克，当我读出那个名单时，你看起来越来越像个新教徒了。这使得维滕贝格成为朝圣的巨大焦点。如果你去敬拜这些圣物——
The twig from the burning bush, as a pilgrim on days that are specially ordained by papal decree, then you can reduce your stay in purgatory by 1,902,202 years and 270 days. You're not going to turn down that as a bargain, are you? I mean, you're not. And people do go to look at things that they know are obviously fake right now. Yeah. But I don't think they do think that. You don't think they do think that? They don't think it's fake because otherwise you wouldn't go, would you?
那根燃烧的荆棘丛中的树枝，作为一名在教皇法令特别规定的日子里的朝圣者，那么你可以减少在炼狱中的停留时间1,902,202年零270天。你不会拒绝这笔交易，对吧？我的意思是，你不会。人们确实去看了他们现在知道显然是假的东西。是的。但我不认为他们认为那是假的。你不认为他们认为那是假的？他们不认为那是假的，因为否则你就不会去了，对吧？
Yeah, you would. People do go to see tourist attractions that are wacky. No, you're not going to travel miles and miles and miles, very arduous and grueling, if you don't believe you're going to benefit from it. But my point is, first of all, I'm not sure about that. And secondly, because I think people, the chance of an expedition is always going to be very exciting to people. But secondly, so we were talking about the nature of belief. And there's always this, people often do, you know, people from the Protestant tradition
是的，你会的。人们确实去参观古怪的旅游景点。不，如果你不相信你会从中受益，你就不会长途跋涉，那是非常艰苦和劳累的。但我的观点是，首先，我不确定这一点。其次，因为我认为人们，探险的机会对人们来说总是非常令人兴奋的。但其次，所以我们刚才在谈论信仰的本质。而且总是这样，人们经常这样做，你知道，来自新教传统的人
do laugh at all this stuff, don't they? And say, what, complete mugs, all this kind of thing. But these are the subject of arguments at the time, aren't they? There are a lot of people who regard themselves as orthodox, in inverted commas, Catholic theologians or writers or whatever, who get very cross about this and say, you're taking the mickey out of something that is serious. That some of these relics are real and they have power,
确实会嘲笑所有这些东西，不是吗？并说：“什么，完全是傻瓜，所有这些东西。”但这些在当时是争论的主题，不是吗？有很多自认为是正统的（加引号）天主教神学家或作家或什么的，他们对此感到非常生气，并说：“你在拿严肃的事情开玩笑。”其中一些圣物是真实的，它们有力量，
but some of them are patently frauds. And actually people will sometimes reject some relics, won't they? They will. But again, to go back to Chaucer's portrayal of the partner in The Canterbury Tales, who's a loathsome figure who is basically scamming people, who is fleecing people, extorting money so that they can reverence fragments of sheep bone and pretending that it's the bone of saints or whatever. But the reason that Chaucer is condemning him, the reason he's such a loathsome figure isn't because relics per se are fraudulent.
但其中一些显然是骗局。实际上人们有时会拒绝一些圣物，不是吗？他们会。但再次回到乔叟在《坎特伯雷故事集》中对“赎罪券贩子”（the pardoner）的描绘，他是一个令人厌恶的人物，基本上是在欺骗人们，在敲诈人们，勒索钱财，以便他们可以敬拜羊骨碎片，并假装那是圣徒的骨头什么的。但乔叟谴责他的原因，他之所以是一个如此令人厌恶的人物，并不是因为圣物本身是欺诈性的。
Exactly. It's that it's exploiting what is a genuine source of hope for people. So Chaucer doesn't discount that relics have this power, but he is condemning people who exploit it. But Tom, the twig from the burning bush? I mean, I cannot be alone in thinking that there must have been an awful lot of people, even in Wittenberg, who thought, come on, a twig from the burning bush? I mean, how's that got here? How's that been preserved over the thousands of years? Well, the fact that you think that, I think, is due to...
完全正确。而是因为它在利用人们真正的希望来源。所以乔叟并不否认圣物有这种力量，但他是在谴责那些利用它的人。但汤姆，燃烧的荆棘丛中的树枝？我的意思是，我不可能是一个人认为，即使在维滕贝格，也一定有很多人想：“得了吧，燃烧的荆棘丛中的树枝？我的意思是，那是怎么到这里的？几千年来它是怎么保存下来的？”嗯，你这么想，我认为是因为……
Lack of imagination on my part. The hero of this episode. Okay, fine. But at this point, he's gone to Wittenberg and in 1512, he gets his doctorate and he becomes the professor of the Bible in the university. And there is lots of scope here for him to really make a name for himself because Frederick wants celebrity professors. And so if Luther can make a name for himself because Frederick wants celebrity professors. And so if Luther can make a name for himself as professor of the Bible, then Frederick will really back him. And we will see in the second part of this episode, because I think we should take a break at this point, how Luther does as professor of the Bible at Wittenberg University, because, well,
我缺乏想象力。这一集的英雄。好吧，没问题。但在这一点上，他去了维滕贝格，在1512年，他获得了博士学位，并成为大学的圣经教授。这里有很大的空间让他真正出名，因为弗雷德里希想要名人教授。所以如果路德能出名……因为弗雷德里希想要名人教授。所以如果路德能作为圣经教授出名，那么弗雷德里希就会真正支持他。我们将在这一集的第二部分看到，因为我认为我们应该在这一点上休息一下，路德作为维滕贝格大学的圣经教授表现如何，因为，嗯，
he's going to have quite a seismic impact. So we will see you in a few minutes. Very good. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
他将产生相当大的地震般的影响。所以我们几分钟后再见。非常好。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History.
在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。
Now, Martin Luther, having gone through this extraordinary experience in a thunderstorm, has become a professor at a new university in Wittenberg, home of some very exciting relics in which Tom believes implicitly. And Tom, he's got his doctorate. He's professor of the Bible in Wittenberg. And I mean, this will lead us on to the question of books, which we'll come to in a minute, but what does a professor of the Bible actually mean? So what's he doing? So he's lecturing on various books in the Bible. And so it means that he is looking very, very closely at scripture. So between 1513 and 15, he is teaching the Psalms. 1515 to 1517, he's teaching the letters of St. Paul. It's kind of deep dives
现在，马丁·路德在雷雨中经历了这次非凡的经历后，已经成为维滕贝格一所新大学的教授，那里有一些汤姆深信不疑的非常令人兴奋的圣物。汤姆，他拿到了博士学位。他是维滕贝格的圣经教授。我的意思是，这将引导我们讨论书籍的问题，我们稍后会谈到，但圣经教授到底意味着什么？所以他在做什么？所以他正在讲授圣经中的各种书籍。这意味着他正在非常、非常仔细地研究经文。所以在1513年到1515年之间，他正在教授《诗篇》。1515年到1517年，他正在教授圣保罗的书信。这是一种深入研究
into key biblical texts. But what's interesting about this is that right from the beginning, Luther seems to have seen this as an opportunity to engage not with what his predecessors have said about the Bible. So, you know, all the various commentaries and analysis and so on, but what he personally thinks about it. So there's a sense that he, Martin Luther, is engaging one-on-one with this great body of scripture. And Tom, that's quite a humanist thing, isn't it? Get back to the sources.
关键的圣经文本。但有趣的是，从一开始，路德似乎就把这视为一个机会，不是去参与他的前任们对圣经说了什么——所以，你知道，所有各种评论和分析等等——而是他个人对它的看法。所以有一种感觉，他，马丁·路德，正在与这伟大的圣经主体进行一对一的接触。汤姆，那是一件非常人文主义的事情，不是吗？回到源头。
Don't worry about the weight of tradition. Just get back to the original stuff. Yeah, but even so, I mean, even humanist scholars would have, say, the scholarly apparatus that might enable you to look at the original Greek or whatever. But Luther makes a point of going to the university printer and asking him to print a kind of a naked text, one without any glosses, any commentaries at all, just the raw text itself. And this is really unusual. So it suggests already that something distinctive about Luther's relationship to the body of the Bible is kicking in. And Tom, that gives us an opportunity to talk about something massive that we haven't talked about at all yet, which actually lies at the very centre of Luther's life and this whole period. And that's obviously printing. Because you could argue, couldn't you,
不要担心传统的重量。只要回到原始的东西。是的，但即便如此，我的意思是，即使是人文主义学者也会有，比如说，学术工具，可能使你能够查看原始希腊语什么的。但路德特意去大学印刷商那里，要求他印刷一种“裸本”，一种没有任何注释、没有任何评论的文本，只有原始文本本身。这真的很不寻常。所以这已经表明，路德与圣经主体之间某种独特的关系正在开始。汤姆，这给了我们一个机会来谈论一些我们还没有谈论过的巨大的事情，它实际上处于路德一生和整个时期的核心。那就是印刷术。因为你可以争辩，不是吗，
the Reformation would not have happened as it did. I'm sure you pretty much would argue that, wouldn't you, that it doesn't happen in the way it does. Yeah, it's absolutely completely fundamental. So the printing story is a really interesting one because Deben McCulloch in his book on the Reformation makes the point that up until quite recently in this period, so up to 1450 or whatever, people had always assumed that all great wisdom and advances had been made in the past and the story of human history was a story of decay since then and nothing had ever improved or changed or got better other than you know it only changed and deteriorating but clearly there
宗教改革不会像那样发生。我相信你几乎会争辩说，不是吗，它不会以那种方式发生。是的，它绝对是完全根本性的。所以印刷故事是一个非常有趣的故事，因为德本·麦卡洛克（Diarmaid MacCulloch）在他的宗教改革著作中指出，直到这个时期的相当晚近，所以直到1450年左右，人们一直认为所有的伟大智慧和进步都是在过去取得的，人类历史的故事是自那时以来的衰落故事，除了你知道，它只是改变和恶化，没有任何东西曾经改进或改变或变得更好，但显然
is one way in which life has got better and that's through you know information technology so first of all they've had paper replacing parchment which is about the 13th century onwards and then in 1450 gutenbergberg's Bible, movable type. And Timmerman McCulloch in his book, he says, of course there had been previous movements very critical of papal authority or kind of church orthodoxy. So we mentioned John Wycliffe and the Lollards, but they didn't have the printing press. They weren't able to easily disseminate their message.
有一种方式让生活变得更好了，那就是通过你知道，信息技术。所以首先，他们有了纸张取代羊皮纸，大约是13世纪以后，然后在1450年，古腾堡的圣经，活字印刷。蒂姆·麦卡洛克在他的书中说，当然之前也有过非常批评教皇权威或教会正统的运动。所以我们提到了约翰·威克里夫（John Wycliffe）和罗拉德派（Lollards），但他们没有印刷机。他们无法轻易传播他们的信息。
And there is an argument, isn't there? John Calvin's prog for Bernard Cotteray, if that's how you pronounce his name, I'm assuming he's a Frenchman or Swiss or something. He says it's the increase in Bibles, the increase in printed Bibles that creates the Reformation, not the other way around. Do you think that's true? I mean, if you look at what Luther is doing, that he is going to the university printer and ordering this Bible without glosses, I mean, that absolutely kind of illustrates it because he would not have been able to do that previously. If he'd wanted that, you know, he would have had to go to a scriptorium, would have spent, you know, years and years writing
而且有一个论点，不是吗？约翰·加尔文（John Calvin）的……如果那是你发音的名字，我假设他是法国人或瑞士人什么的。他说，是圣经的增加，印刷圣经的增加创造了宗教改革，而不是反过来。你认为那是真的吗？我的意思是，如果你看看路德在做什么，他去大学印刷商那里订购这本没有注释的圣经，我的意思是，那绝对说明了这一点，因为他以前不可能做到这一点。如果他想要那个，你知道，他将不得不去缮写室，将不得不花费，你知道，几年又几年地写
out about it, you know, it just wouldn't be possible to do it. But now it is. And isn't there also an argument that the nature of thinking changes with printing? So again, in McCulloch's book, he says, if you're a scholar in the 12th century or the 13th century, you work out what you do with your time in the day. You copy out books. I mean, that's how you spend your time. You don't have time to think about them. You are preserving the wisdom of the ancients in a world where it will deteriorate, where the parchment will rot or become destroyed in a fire or whatever. So it's really important. Right. Yeah. So it's becoming more accessible in exactly the way that the internet has made texts more accessible.
出来，你知道，这根本不可能做到。但现在可以了。而且难道没有一种论点认为，思维的本质随着印刷而改变了吗？所以再次在麦卡洛克的书中，他说，如果你是12世纪或13世纪的学者，你安排你一天的时间做什么。你抄写书籍。我的意思是，这就是你度过时间的方式。你没有时间去思考它们。你是在一个智慧会恶化、羊皮纸会腐烂或在火灾中被毁坏的世界里保存古人的智慧。所以这真的很重要。对。是的。所以它变得越来越容易获得，就像互联网使文本更容易获得一样。
And the parallel is one that has often been made. In fact, we made it, I think in our fourth or fifth episode we ever did, the parallel between the impact of the printing press on Reformation Europe and the impact of the internet on today's world. But you can see, I think, I mean, just that thing of Luther with his Bible. As you say, he doesn't have to spend lots of time kind of getting it written out. He can just have it. And also the fact that although he's still a monk, but now he's a university professor, he has the time to really focus in on it. I mean, this is what enables him to get to grips with scripture, with the text in a way that he wouldn't have been possible if he'd become a monk, say a century before. It just wouldn't have been possible. And isn't he also, isn't the other thing about printing and reading and the book, you experience that. It's just you in the book, right? It's not a collective thing. It's not
这种类比经常被提及。事实上，我想我们在第四或第五期节目中就提到过，即印刷术对宗教改革时期的欧洲的影响与互联网对当今世界的影响之间的类比。但你可以看到，我想说的是，路德和他的圣经就是个例子。如你所说，他不必花大量时间去抄写。他可以直接拥有它。而且，尽管他仍然是一名僧侣，但现在他也是一名大学教授，他有时间真正专注于此。我的意思是，这使他能够以一种如果他早一个世纪成为僧侣就不可能实现的方式来理解经文和文本。这根本是不可能的。而且，关于印刷、阅读和书籍，还有一点，你体验到的是一种个人化的过程。只有你和书，对吧？这不是集体行为。它不是
mediated by an institution. Well, it can be in a monastery because the monk would read out from the Bible while people are dining or whatever. But at a university, yes, absolutely. Yeah. It doesn't have to be that way. And all the people who are going to be the audience of Protestantism, lawyers, merchants, the gentry, people who can read and perhaps own books or aspire to own books. So to have that private experience with the word of God, it means by definition you have a more individualistic ethos. You have a sense of religion, learning, the world of the mind, being just you and the
由机构调解的。嗯，在修道院里可能是这样，因为僧侣会在人们用餐时朗读圣经。但在大学里，绝对不是。是的。它不必非得那样。所有那些将成为新教受众的人，律师、商人、绅士，那些识字并可能拥有书籍或渴望拥有书籍的人。因此，能够与上帝的话语进行那种私密的体验，意味着从定义上讲，你拥有了一种更具个人主义的特质。你有一种宗教感、学习感，心灵的世界，仅仅是你和
text, not somebody else telling you what to make of a text that you perhaps don't even get to access yourself. So it's a classic example of the interface between technology and culture. And I mean, just so Luther talking about his his experience teaching the Bible with this text, being able, as you said, to have a kind of personal relationship with it. Much later in his life, he said, if you picture the Bible to be a mighty tree and every word a little branch, I have shaken every one of these branches because I wanted to know what it was and what it meant. And the consequence of this is that increasingly he is establishing his
文本，而不是别人告诉你该如何理解你甚至可能无法亲自接触到的文本。所以这是技术与文化之间相互作用的经典例子。我的意思是，路德谈到他用这段文本教授圣经的经历，正如你所说，能够与之建立一种个人关系。在他晚年时，他说，如果你把圣经想象成一棵大树，每一个字都是一根小树枝，我已经摇动了每一根树枝，因为我想知道它是什么，它意味着什么。而这样做的结果是，他越来越确立了自己的
own understanding of what scripture says. And because he doesn't have all those glosses, because he doesn't have the commentaries, it is something that is very distinctive to him. And by 1517, which is the year in which he will publish the 95 Theses on Indulgences. So he publishes the 95 Theses in the autumn. But that summer, he writes up 97 Theses in which he is coming to some very, very radical conclusions. In fact, more radical than the more famous 95 Theses. So in these Theses, he is essentially rejecting the entire structure of medieval theology, particularly Aristotle, the great philosopher, whose philosophy in the 13th century had begun to be interwoven by scholars. Yeah, because Aristotle is living in the age of Alexander
对经文含义的理解。因为他没有那些注释，没有那些评注，所以这是他非常独特的东西。到了1517年，也就是他发表《九十五条论纲》的那一年。他在秋天发表了《九十五条论纲》。但在那年夏天，他写下了97条论纲，其中他得出了一些非常、非常激进的结论。事实上，比更著名的《九十五条论纲》还要激进。因此，在这些论纲中，他本质上是在拒绝中世纪神学的整个结构，特别是亚里士多德，这位伟大的哲学家，他的哲学在13世纪开始被学者们交织在一起。是的，因为亚里士多德生活在亚历山大
the Great. He's not a Christian. Right. But he gets integrated with the fabric of medieval theology. And Luther comes to think that this is mad. And so he says, you know, one of his propositions is that no one can become a theologian unless he becomes one without Aristotle. And he, all his life, will hate Aristotle, a damned, arrogant, roguish, heathen, author of the worst books ever written. So great review. That's worse than some of my reviews.
大帝的时代。他不是基督徒。没错。但他被整合到了中世纪神学的结构中。路德开始认为这简直是疯了。所以他说，你知道，他的主张之一是，除非一个人在没有亚里士多德的情况下成为神学家，否则他无法成为神学家。他一生都憎恨亚里士多德，称他为该死的、傲慢的、无赖的、异教徒，是有史以来最糟糕书籍的作者。真是个伟大的评价。这比我的一些评论还要糟糕。
And so what he is emphasizing is you don't need Aristotle. You don't need all this philosophy. You don't need all this massive, great structure that the medieval church has been erecting. What you need is, in Latin, sola scriptura, the Bible alone. That's all you need. It's you and the Bible, and that's all you need. And Tom, is that because he also distrusts the stuff about Aristotle? You know, Aristotle integrating that with Christianity and Greek thoughts and stuff.
所以他强调的是，你不需要亚里士多德。你不需要所有这些哲学。你不需要中世纪教会建立的所有这些庞大的结构。你需要的是，用拉丁语说，唯独圣经（sola scriptura），只有圣经。这就是你所需要的全部。只有你和圣经，这就是你所需要的全部。汤姆，这是因为他也怀疑关于亚里士多德的东西吗？你知道，亚里士多德将它与基督教、希腊思想等结合在一起。
It's all like, let's spend decades with these very complicated kind of intellectual puzzles, working out all definitions of things and exploring the ramifications of them. And he distrusts that because he thinks human reason is necessarily corrupt and sinful and evil. He does. And he thinks that again, very, very profoundly. So another of his 97 theses published that summer of 1517, the truth is that the human being corrupted to the root can neither desire nor perform anything but evil. And so this is an explanation for why Luther has been unable to win the love of God by doing good works or whatever. Effectively, what he's saying is that that entire doctrine is nonsense, that there's no way that you
这就像是，让我们花几十年时间研究这些非常复杂的智力难题，找出所有事物的定义并探索它们的后果。他对此表示怀疑，因为他认为人类的理性必然是腐败、罪恶和邪恶的。他确实这么认为。而且他对此有非常、非常深刻的认识。所以他在1517年那个夏天发表的97条论纲中的另一条是，事实是，人类从根本上腐败，除了邪恶之外，既不能渴望也不能做出任何事情。所以这就是为什么路德无法通过行善或其他方式赢得上帝的爱。实际上，他所说的是，整个教义都是胡说八道，你根本没有办法
can do it, that humans are so shot through with sin that you cannot win salvation for yourself. Tom, is that not what St. Augustine thought about original sin and all that kind of thing, that we were wicked and no amount of, you know, only God could make us good. It wasn't in our own power, the power of our own puny minds to make us good. Is that right? Well, there are kind of various interpretations of what Augustine taught, but that is certainly one interpretation. And of course, Luther is an Augustinian, so he's very aware of that. So he would have been focusing absolutely on what Augustine is teaching. And also Augustine is writing in the context of what St. Paul wrote. So all of this is kind of bubbling away in Luther's mind, this sense that he cannot reach God because humans are completely sinful, which in turn means that the devil is all the more terrifying. Oh yeah, because of course he's obsessed with the devil, right?
做到这一点，人类充满了罪恶，以至于你无法为自己赢得救赎。汤姆，那不是圣奥古斯丁关于原罪之类的想法吗，我们是邪恶的，无论怎么做，只有上帝才能让我们变好。这不是我们自己的力量，我们自己微小的头脑没有能力让我们变好。是这样吗？嗯，关于奥古斯丁的教导有各种各样的解释，但这无疑是一种解释。当然，路德是一名奥古斯丁派修士，所以他非常清楚这一点。所以他会绝对专注于奥古斯丁所教导的内容。而且奥古斯丁也是在圣保罗所写内容的背景下写作的。所以所有这些都在路德的脑海中翻腾，这种感觉是他无法接近上帝，因为人类是完全有罪的，这反过来意味着魔鬼更加可怕。哦，是的，因为他当然沉迷于魔鬼，对吧？
Does he think the devil is Lucifer, the fallen angel? Is that what he thinks? Yeah. And he thinks the devil is literally everywhere. He's in your cup of tea. He's lurking behind the furniture. He's in everything. He permeates the world.
他认为魔鬼是路西法，那个堕落的天使吗？他是这么想的吗？是的。而且他认为魔鬼简直无处不在。他在你的茶杯里。他潜伏在家具后面。他在一切事物中。他渗透了整个世界。
Is that right? Yeah. And particularly that the devil inhabits, I mean, you could call it a dimension of shit. And I use the word advisedly. So people who think that Luther is a theologian and therefore very abstract, I mean, in some senses he is, but in other senses, he is unbelievably earthy. And his understanding of theology is very, very rooted in the physical. And his understanding, say, of the devil, the devil is to be imagined as inhabiting the dimension of shit. So you love that phrase.
是这样吗？是的。特别是魔鬼居住在，我的意思是，你可以称之为屎的维度。我慎重地使用了这个词。所以那些认为路德是一位神学家，因此非常抽象的人，我的意思是，在某种意义上他是，但在其他意义上，他令人难以置信地粗俗。他对神学的理解非常、非常扎根于物质层面。他对魔鬼的理解，比如说，魔鬼被想象成居住在屎的维度里。所以你很喜欢这个短语。
And back in 1515, Luther had been appointed by Staupitz to give a ceremonial sermon before all the monks in his monastery. And he focuses in on the theme of backbiting. And Luther says, A slanderer does nothing but ruminate the filth of others with his own teeth and wallow like a pig with his nose in the dirt. This is also why his shit stinks most, surpassed only by the devils. And though man drops his shit in private, the slanderer does not respect this privacy.
早在1515年，路德就被施陶皮茨任命在他修道院的所有僧侣面前发表仪式性的布道。他专注于诽谤这个主题。路德说，诽谤者除了用自己的牙齿反刍他人的污秽，像猪一样把鼻子埋在泥土里打滚之外，什么也不做。这也是为什么他的屎最臭，只有魔鬼的屎能超过它。虽然人在私下里排泄，但诽谤者并不尊重这种隐私。
He gluts on the pleasure of wallowing in it, and he does not deserve better according to god's righteous judgment okay well you've really doubled down on that word yeah yeah and um heiko oberman a dutch scholar who wrote um a brilliant book translated as luther man between god and the devil yeah he has a brilliant section on this talking about how the deliberate earthiness, I mean, you might almost say kind of scatological quality of Luther's language, that what he's doing there, and to quote Obermann, it's expressive of the painful battle fought body and soul against the adversary who threatens both flesh and spirit. So Theo is asking a question I would ask, which is
他沉溺于在其中打滚的快感，根据上帝公正的审判，他不值得更好的待遇。好吧，你真的在这个词上加倍强调了。是的，是的，还有，海科·奥伯曼，一位荷兰学者，写了一本精彩的书，翻译为《路德：上帝与魔鬼之间的人》，是的，他有一个精彩的章节讨论了这种刻意的粗俗，我的意思是，你几乎可以说是一种路德语言的排泄学特质，他在那里所做的是，引用奥伯曼的话，这表达了身体和灵魂与威胁肉体和精神的对手之间进行的痛苦战斗。所以西奥问了一个我会问的问题，那就是
you've used that word multiple times. Is that the word that Luther would have used? He wouldn't have said excrement? Well, he's doing it in Latin, but it's a form of Latin that is best translated in a kind of colloquial. It's not kind of, ooh, stools or excrement. Right. He has picked a very vulgar word. He's deliberately picked it. And he's preaching this as in a sermon before all his fellow monks so it's not like he's anything particularly exceptional there but i think actually in his obsession with the scatological as we will see in due course he is and so he has this very very vivid earthy sense of the danger that sin represents, kind of founded in latrines and-
你多次使用了那个词。那是路德会使用的词吗？他不会说排泄物吗？嗯，他是在用拉丁语说，但那是一种最好用口语翻译的拉丁语形式。它不是那种，哦，粪便或排泄物。没错。他选择了一个非常粗俗的词。他是故意选择它的。而且他是在他所有僧侣同僚面前的布道中宣讲这个词，所以他并没有什么特别之处，但我认为实际上，正如我们稍后将看到的，他对排泄学的痴迷确实是独特的。所以他有一种非常、非常生动、粗俗的危险感，这种危险感是由罪恶所代表的，扎根于厕所和——
Toilets, yeah. Excrement and toilets and all kinds of things. But also, he is starting to develop a sense that perhaps there is a way of getting beyond this, of reaching beyond all the kind of paraphernalia of the medieval church and having a kind of more personal relationship with God. But as yet, I think it's not entirely formed. But a thing then happens that focuses these inchoate feelings. It changes everything.
厕所，是的。排泄物和厕所，以及各种各样的东西。但同时，他开始产生一种感觉，也许有一种方法可以超越这一切，超越中世纪教会的所有那些繁文缛节，与上帝建立一种更个人的关系。但目前，我认为它还没有完全形成。但随后发生了一件事，使这些模糊的感觉集中起来。它改变了一切。
It changes everything. And this is the moment that we began this series with, which is his opposition to indulgences. And it's triggered by something that happens that autumn, which is his opposition to indulgences. And it's triggered by something that happens that autumn, which is that a kind of an entire indulgence selling roadshow comes rolling into Saxony. And it's led by a friar, so a Dominican, so not an Augustinian. So there's a kind of instinctively, you know, there's a great rivalry between Dominicans and Augustinians. And this friar is called Johann Tetzel. And it's a great show. He's accompanied by officials.
它改变了一切。这就是我们开始这个系列时提到的时刻，即他反对赎罪券。这是由那年秋天发生的事情触发的，即他反对赎罪券。这是由那年秋天发生的事情触发的，即一种兜售赎罪券的巡回演出进入了萨克森。它由一名修士领导，所以是一名多米尼克派修士，而不是奥古斯丁派修士。所以有一种本能的，你知道，多米尼克派和奥古斯丁派之间有巨大的竞争。这位修士叫约翰·特策尔。这是一场盛大的表演。他有官员陪同。
He's got people to carry the papal coat of arms on a cross. He's got all these indulgences that have been issued by the Pope, and they're kind of laid out on a velvet cushion. And he comes in, and the reason that he wants to make a show is he wants to draw a crowd and the moment the crowd is there he launches into a sermon and it's an absolutely shameless hard sell yeah you know he's saying buy this indulgence or all your relatives your parents or whoever your loved ones will be writhing in the flames love it he notoriously claims that um his indulgences are so effective that even if someone had raped the Virgin Mary,
他让人在十字架上扛着教皇的纹章。他有教皇颁发的所有这些赎罪券，它们被铺在天鹅绒垫子上。他进来了，他想要表演的原因是他想吸引人群，一旦人群聚集，他就开始布道，这绝对是厚颜无耻的硬推销。是的，你知道他在说，买这张赎罪券，否则你所有的亲戚、父母或任何你所爱的人都会在火焰中挣扎。太棒了。他臭名昭著地声称，嗯，他的赎罪券非常有效，即使有人强奸了圣母玛利亚，
he would be assured complete remission of purgatory. And even though indulgences are not supposed to be sold, so it's not like, you know, get out of purgatory and pay me whatever. You make the offering, you know, as you might do a good work or go on a pilgrimage or whatever. But Tetzel basically is so blatant about it that a notorious jingle is attributed to him. Never actually appears in the record of his sermons, but it is in all the sources attributed to him. As soon as the coin in the coffer rings, the soul from purgatory springs. We would never behave like that in the rest of history, would we?
他也会被保证完全免除炼狱。尽管赎罪券不应该被出售，所以这不像，你知道，付钱给我就能离开炼狱。你做出奉献，你知道，就像你可能做善事或去朝圣一样。但特策尔基本上对此非常明目张胆，以至于一个臭名昭著的顺口溜被归功于他。从未真正出现在他的布道记录中，但在所有来源中都归功于他。钱币在钱箱中叮当响，灵魂从炼狱中跳出来。我们在历史的其他部分永远不会那样做，对吧？
We're there. We would never advertise products so seamlessly. We would never, never hard sell. No, we'd never do that. So it's pretty nakedly corrupt. Yeah. And you have to wonder, well, why is the church tolerating it? And the reason for that is that basically everyone is benefiting from it.
我们就在那里。我们永远不会如此无缝地推销产品。我们永远、永远不会硬推销。不，我们永远不会那样做。所以这相当赤裸裸地腐败。是的。你不得不怀疑，嗯，为什么教会容忍它？原因基本上是每个人都从中受益。
So this money that is being raised by Tetzel is supposedly going to Rome to pay for the rebuilding of St. Peter's. Well, that's a really important thing, Tom, because the Pope wants to rebuild St. Peter's because the Pope previously, decades ago, was out of Rome and Rome fell into total dereliction. And all monarchs, the Pope included, are really kind of tooling up, aren't they? At the beginning of the 16th century, they've got a bit more power, they want greater display, they want more grandiose statements like Henry VIII. So the Pope wants in on that too, and he wants to rebuild St Peter's as an earthly statement, as well as a sort of spiritual one, of his new power and his confidence. Is that right? So it's expensive, but it's beneficial. You know, it's the Holy Father.
所以特策尔筹集的这些钱据说是要去罗马支付重建圣彼得大教堂的费用。嗯，那是一件非常重要的事情，汤姆，因为教皇想要重建圣彼得大教堂，因为教皇之前，几十年前，不在罗马，罗马陷入了彻底的荒废。所有的君主，包括教皇，都在真正地武装自己，不是吗？在16世纪初，他们有了更多的权力，他们想要更大的展示，他们想要像亨利八世那样更宏伟的声明。所以教皇也想参与其中，他想重建圣彼得大教堂作为一种世俗的声明，以及一种精神上的声明，展示他的新权力和信心。是这样吗？所以它很昂贵，但它是有益的。你知道，这是圣父。
So it's perfectly legitimate that the money raised from this might go to it. But in fact, only half of it is going to the Pope because the rest of it is going to a family of bankers in Augsburg called the Fuggers. Yeah. Well, they're huge names in the early 16th century, the Fuggers. They're the great banking dynasty, aren't they? Yeah. So they're the ones who published the newspaper that report the conquest of the Aztecs. Exactly. We mentioned in our series. And the reason that the money is going to them is because
所以从这笔钱中筹集的资金用于此是完全合法的。但事实上，只有一半流向了教皇，因为其余的流向了奥格斯堡的一个银行家家族，叫富格尔家族。是的。嗯，他们在16世纪初是响当当的名字，富格尔家族。他们是伟大的银行王朝，不是吗？是的。所以他们是发布报道征服阿兹特克人新闻的人。正是如此。我们在我们的系列中提到过。钱流向他们的原因是
basically the Archbishop of Mainz, so big cheese in Germany, who's the younger son of a princely family in the Holy Roman Emperor, a man called Albaricte. And he owes the Fuggers 21,000 ducats. And the reason that he owes them 21,000 ducats is because he has agreed to pay that sum to the Pope as a donation to the building of St. Peter's. And the reason he's agreed to do that is because he is effectively bribing the Pope because he's a very young man. He's only 27.
基本上美因茨大主教，德国的大人物，他是神圣罗马帝国一个王室家族的幼子，一个叫阿尔布雷希特的人。他欠富格尔家族21,000杜卡特。他欠他们21,000杜卡特的原因是他同意向教皇支付这笔钱作为建造圣彼得大教堂的捐款。他同意这样做的原因是，他实际上是在贿赂教皇，因为他非常年轻。他只有27岁。
He's already the bishop of two bishoprics, two cities. And now the Archbishopric of Mainz has come free. He wants that as well. And to get the Pope to agree to this, this is why he's paying him all this money. And one more thing, Tom, he wants to become the Archbishop of Mainz because it's one of the seven electors of the Holy Roman Empire. So it really matters to him to get it and he will do whatever it takes financially to get his hands on that post for his family, for his dynasty. And so everything kind of connects, the politics, banking, the church. It does. And everyone is benefiting. Yeah. The Fuggers get rich. Albrecht gets his Archbishopric. The Pope gets lots of money to build St. Peter's. Yeah. And all the faithful
他已经是两个主教区、两个城市的主教了。现在美因茨大主教区空缺了。他也想要那个。为了让教皇同意这一点，这就是他支付所有这些钱的原因。还有一件事，汤姆，他想成为美因茨大主教，因为它是神圣罗马帝国的七个选帝侯之一。所以为了他的家族，为了他的王朝，得到这个职位对他来说非常重要，他会不惜一切代价在经济上得到那个职位。所以一切都联系在一起，政治、银行、教会。确实如此。每个人都受益。是的。富格尔家族变得富有。阿尔布雷希特得到了他的大主教职位。教皇得到了很多钱来建造圣彼得大教堂。是的。所有的信徒
get to get out of purgatory. Brilliant. Everyone wins. Actually, not everyone wins because Frederick doesn't win because he doesn't want Tetzel coming and distracting from his relic collection. So Tetzel is not actually allowed into Wittenberg. Because you're not going to go to see a relic if you can buy an indulgence instead. No. So Tetzel bases himself about 20 miles northeast of Wittenberg. But obviously news of his activities reaches Wittenberg and it reaches Luther. And Luther absolutely explodes because it's expressive of everything that he is coming to doubt. He regards all this kind of indulgent stuff as a scam. And that sense would definitely be sharpened if he'd known what Albrecht was up to. So he doesn't know that
都能离开炼狱。太棒了。每个人都赢了。实际上，并非每个人都赢了，因为弗雷德里克没有赢，因为他不希望特策尔来分散对他圣物收藏的注意力。所以特策尔实际上不被允许进入维滕贝格。因为如果你能买到赎罪券，你就不会去看圣物了。不。所以特策尔把基地设在维滕贝格东北约20英里处。但显然他活动的消息传到了维滕贝格，也传到了路德那里。路德彻底爆发了，因为这表达了他开始怀疑的一切。他认为所有这些赎罪券之类的东西都是骗局。如果他知道阿尔布雷希特在做什么，那种感觉肯定会更加强烈。所以他不知道
Albrecht is a direct beneficiary of these indulgences. But it doesn't stop him from launching, in his thesis that he writes up, he launches a very, very direct attack on the archbishop. Luther writes, on no occasion has christ ordered that indulgences should be preached what a horror what a danger for a bishop to permit the loud noise of indulgences among his people while the gospel is silenced and to be more concerned with the sale of indulgences than with the gospel so very very forthright and you know this is one of the 95 theses that he will promulgate on the 31st of october which is All Hallows' Eve. Yeah.
阿尔布雷希特是这些赎罪券的直接受益者。但这并没有阻止他在他写下的论纲中对大主教发动非常、非常直接的攻击。路德写道，基督在任何情况下都没有命令应该宣扬赎罪券，主教允许在他的子民中发出赎罪券的喧嚣，而福音却被压制，并且比起福音更关心赎罪券的销售，这是一种多么可怕、多么危险的事情。所以非常、非常直率，你知道，这是他将在10月31日，也就是万圣节前夜颁布的95条论纲之一。是的。
And Wittenberg is full of pilgrims because they've all come to mark the festival on the 1st of November to go to Frederick's relic collection. They're coming to look at the burning bush and the corpse of the person killed by King Herod. All of that. Now, at the beginning of this series, we read from Richard Rex's book on Luther.
维滕贝格挤满了朝圣者，因为他们都来纪念11月1日的节日，去参观弗雷德里克的圣物收藏。他们来看燃烧的荆棘和被希律王杀害的人的尸体。所有这些。现在，在这个系列的开头，我们读了理查德·雷克斯关于路德的书。
Yeah. An account. Nailing their theses to the door, Tom. But as Rex in his book goes to point out, and he's absolutely not alone in doing this, it almost certainly didn't happen. What? Luther never actually mentions it. After two hours, you let us down like this.
是的。一个记录。把他们的论纲钉在门上，汤姆。但正如雷克斯在他的书中指出的那样，而且他绝对不是唯一一个这样做的人，这几乎肯定没有发生。什么？路德从未真正提到过它。两个小时后，你让我们失望了。
But just wait. So the earliest appearance of the story isn't isn't until 1546 and the truth is actually that if it had happened as you know the tradition says it wouldn't have had much impact because actually professors going and pasting things on doors or nailing them on doors this is par for the course there's nothing particularly exceptional about it right what luther actually does is much more radical. He has his theses printed. And again, this goes back to what you were saying about the importance of the printing press. If he'd just written them up and put them on the doors of a church in an obscure university town,
但请稍等。所以这个故事最早的出现是在1546年，事实是，如果它像你知道的传统所说的那样发生了，它也不会产生太大的影响，因为实际上教授们去把东西贴在门上或钉在门上，这是常态，没有什么特别之处，对吧？路德实际上做的是更激进的事情。他把他的论纲印刷了出来。同样，这回到了你所说的印刷机的重要性。如果他只是把它们写下来并贴在一个偏僻大学城教堂的门上，
it wouldn't have had the impact. But he prints them off, and so they can be sent out across the empire. And specifically, he sends them to his superiors in the Augustinian order, to various movers and shakers across Germany, and to the archbishop himself, to Albrecht in Mainz. And of course, this is a very modern strategy, using new technology to promote your message. They can't go viral. Yeah. It's not an analog approach, Dominic. It's a digital approach. Right. And they do indeed go viral with huge consequences. One might say that the storm
它就不会产生这种影响。但他把它们印了出来，这样它们就可以被发送到整个帝国。具体来说，他把它们发送给了奥古斯丁教团的上级，发送给了德国各地的各种推动者和影响者，并发送给了大主教本人，即美因茨的阿尔布雷希特。当然，这是一种非常现代的策略，利用新技术来推广你的信息。它们不能病毒式传播。是的。这不是模拟方法，多米尼克。这是一种数字方法。没错。它们确实病毒式传播了，并产生了巨大的后果。人们可能会说，宗教改革的
clouds of reformation are gathering over Christendom, Dominic. Oh my word. With the shamelessness of Johann Tetzel. There we go. Well, actually, talking of the shamelessness of Johann Tetzel, this is an amazing cliffhanger. So Luther has detonated this bomb, his truth bomb, which is going to completely revolutionize European politics, culture, and thought. And actually, if you want to find out what happened next, you just have to sign up to the Restless History Club. Remember, as soon as the coin and the coffer rings, the episode from Theo's basement springs. Same. So, yeah. I mean, why would you want to risk your immortal soul? Join up to the Restless History Club now and you can hear all the rest. And on that bombshell, Tom, thank you very much and we'll see you next time. Bye-bye. Bye bye. Bye bye.
风暴云正在基督教世界聚集，多米尼克。天哪。随着约翰·特策尔的厚颜无耻。就是这样。好吧，实际上，说到约翰·特策尔的厚颜无耻，这是一个惊人的悬念。所以路德引爆了这枚炸弹，他的真理炸弹，这将彻底彻底改变欧洲的政治、文化和思想。实际上，如果你想知道接下来发生了什么，你只需要注册Restless History Club。记住，钱币在钱箱中叮当响，西奥地下室的剧集就跳出来。一样。所以，是的。我的意思是，你为什么要冒着失去不朽灵魂的风险呢？现在就加入Restless History Club，你可以听到剩下的所有内容。带着这个重磅炸弹，汤姆，非常感谢你，我们下次见。再见。再见。再见。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、奖励内容。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。